[Music]
you mentioned 50 cent uh earlier
you bought yourself a bentley after you
and 50 cent hung out for a while you you
decided to thank you for pronouncing it
correctly right by the way 50 cent
because i used to call him 50 cent and
he's like it's fitty yeah and i couldn't
i was like can we just call you
something what is the real name what
does it say on his driver's license did
it say f-i-t-t-y what does it say fitty
or does it say 50. i'm pretty sure he
doesn't have a driver's license
he has to drive her he doesn't have to
drive himself
fantastic i've got to get to this
bentley the bentley you own a bentley
what are you doing driving around in a
bentley well i thought it was funny
because i was dating a rapper i thought
it wouldn't be funny if i got a bentley
and then i got it as a joke and i kind
of liked it and so i still drive it okay
what kind of car do you drive i have a
ford taurus no you don't
ford taurus sho you do not have a ford
1993. that thing's that thing's a wolf
in sheep's
hops off the highway man you don't see
that thing coming i don't i grew up i
grew up with
i grew up with a father who was a used
car dealer so i have to i mean to me a
car is like really important because i
grew up with cars that had like two
tires and a half a window i mean things
were not when i grew up my dad had a our
family car was a 63 uh chevrolet impala
and it was so rusted on the floor that
the floor fell out and they would drive
us to school in the morning and you
could see the road passing
we were like the flintstones you put
your feet down and accelerate what kind
of car did you have growing up uh
growing up my brother and i shared a uh
buick century oh wow really really sexy
it was the
[Laughter]
i love that reference uh
um uh well so do you so you like about
like do you drive the bentley only to
special places or do you go anywhere
what happened to me yesterday i drove my
bentley i was going to do a shoot for
this my friend of mine i was doing a
favor for a friend and i saw wendy's
okay and i haven't
seen a wendy i grew up in new jersey so
wendy's was very important to me chicken
nuggets they have the real ones they had
the real ones and
mcdonald's doesn't so i went i saw the
wendy's and i'm like oh my god i have to
go through a drive-through i haven't had
fast food in a really long time i
haven't gone through a drive-through by
myself
because i you know i'm super successful
and so i
so i would i go and i don't even think
about it you know when you forget that
you're a celebrity like you don't i
don't think about it you know i'm always
picking my nose and people like oh hey
chelsea and i'm like oh
and so anyway so
sorry i'm used to saying that on my show
so i um
so i go through the drive through and
they're like oh it's chelsea chelsea
handler chelsea lately and i'm at this
point i'm in the drive-through going uh
and like can we get a picture and i'm
like well
together you're just going to take one
of me with the nuggets like what
that's a great picture how is this going
to work because usually you can get in a
photo with someone i'm happy to do that
but when you're in the drive-through i'm
sitting there and i'm like well i
i don't want to have the bag in my hand
taking a photo and they're just taking
photos of me in the drive-through and i
can't get out because i'm sandwiched
between cars and i'm like oh this is so
annoying i should have known never to
take my bentley to a drive
the problems you had i should have at
least switched cars yeah these are the
people this bentley is ruining my
nuggets
[Laughter]